[موسيقى]
لان هذه البلدان كانت ترى في روسيا اكبر
تهديد امنيا وجيوس سياسيا لسلامه اراضيها
وسيادتها وخلال فتره الثلاثين عاما
الماضيه ظلت الضمانات الامنيه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده الى جانب حلف الناتو
تمثل الاولويه القصوى بالنسبه الى هذه
البلدان بعد خروجها من حلف وارسو وانهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي
[موسيقى]
الوحيد لتحقيق ذلك برايها كان الحصول على
العضويه في حلف شمال الاطلسي لضمان حصولها
على الحمايه الامريكيه الدائمه
[موسيقى]
فقد احتلت هذه المساله المرتبه الثانيه
وبعد مرور 30 عاما نرى نفس الموقف المتشدد
تتبناه بلدان اوروبا الشرقيه التي لا ترى
ان فرنسا والمانيا التي تمثلان المحرك
لعمليه التكامل في اوروبا فضلا عن وجود
سياسه للامن والدفاع لدى اوروبا التي ينظر
اليها على انها اليه ذات مصداقيه فيما يخص
توفير الامن لضمان سلامه اراضي هذه
البلدان
[موسيقى]